so i thought that that free trial was
going to solve all my problems
but i'm trying to watch the truman show
it doesn't come with the subscription
or whatever so i have to pay tonight
3.99
my name is irish and for the next week
i'm going to be documenting everything i
spend money on
one of my spending vices used to be
buying records and just given the
uncertainty of everything i was like i
can put the records on hold for a sec
before i would only really spend my
money on like experiences
now i use the lack of spending in those
areas as an excuse to spend
in other areas so now i'm like online
shopping
ordering out every other meal i think
you're gonna see me buying a lot of food
all right so we're both our 20s how do
you think you're gonna do like spending
wise
i buy food every day that's my thing too
i actually buy like three meals a day my
bank account would prefer me to be like
you have one big meal like have that be
my only spending recently i've been
doing a lot of retail therapy
i'm like oh i'm sad like i deserve this
dress that i
probably have itself exactly i feel like
at the end of the week i don't think i'm
gonna be surprised with how much i spent
but i do think i'm gonna be disappointed
i've gotten my bank account wrecked
before by myself
so if that didn't do it then this isn't
going to do it well i guess all we can
do is just see what happens and check
back at the end of the week we're fine
we're going to be fine either way
we have obtained lunch lazy i didn't
want to make one at home even though i
very well could have
i wanted something sweet so we got
milkshakes we got two of them
worth it today's events include a picnic
sometimes you need to spend some money
to get some serotonin
so i had to jump down and grab myself an
iced
coffee i just finished a workday and now
i'm going into a second one
i gotta make money to spend money i'm
currently deciding between
bagel and cream cheese which is at my
house or i could go out
but then i have to spend money i broke
for this beautiful
piece of art was 986
i had the coffee and i had these two
little egg things
that's all i've eaten all day it's time
for my big meal i got burgers and fries
we'll be drinking water though trying to
stay a little bit healthy i did go out
last night to the store and buy bananas
and like a
12 pack of lacroix but i only did that
because
i like made this beautiful oatmeal i
feel proud of myself this morning
significantly less satisfying than
store-bought coffee
it's 6 30 p.m and i'm grabbing a coffee
i ate at home though i have to buy
another textbook
damn school is expensive order complete
literally not even two minutes later and
i just feel like i need to buy another
textbook
also to pay rent in like two days all
right
i just got off work my girl made us our
lunch
i had to pick something i'm here at jack
in the box
i'm about to run up a 20 bill for the
two of us
and then i finally get two days off who
needs a restaurant when you have a chef
done i was blessed with coffee today but
my girl bought it for me so i don't have
to pay for it it's
thursday this is technically my saturday
so i got myself some tacos
but don't worry i'm still gonna have a
big meal tonight
we're doubling up today i found this
really cool
thing by mount rainier it's like a
gondola that takes you to like the top
of this other mountain
i literally just paid my friend so like
my bank account is
not happy but it's worth it it's gonna
be a really cute date i need to impress
her
it went really really well i'm
definitely glad that i spent the money
on it
all right y'all it is friday friday is
grocery day
now i can head over to the farmers
market we're looking at
some bavarian kefir cheese some regular
cheese baguette sourdough
and then this is what we got at the
grocery store itself
overall i had spent a hundred five
dollars on
groceries that i plan on using next week
after a long day of spending
no money we decided to come out to
dinner
and we got sweet on yonki and this like
i don't know
salad and the grand total
and i think we went out with a bang
we've made it to the end of the week
all right let's look at what we both
spent i guess we should just start with
rent i
spent 8.75 that's my half i live with my
girlfriend she takes care of the other
half
i spent 12 hundred dollars on rent and
that is
my share of my three bedrooms we have
saying that out loud like hurts
welcome to hell a everybody knows la is
kind of ridiculously
priced it's all like updated we do have
a washer dryer in unit like it's a
really nice complex
but like i'm paying for the palm trees
i'm paying for the hollywood sign you
know what i mean proximity that's right
all right i feel like food is gonna be
like the really bad one for both of us
because we both said like we'd be
snacking
i spent a total of 262 dollars
on food i spent a total of 207
and 48 cents on food i spent
significantly less than you and like
a hundred of my spending was on the last
day i'm not doing good
bro you better reevaluate your food
spending that is because
when i go and go and get food i'm
usually getting it for me
and my girlfriend because i can't just
go out to eat by myself because that's
the same thing as cheating actually
i ended up going to the grocery store by
the end of the week for the last couple
days i've been eating three meals a day
bro oh my god king
entertainment was lower than i expected
i spent 120
we've been doing one bad movie per week
listened to a podcast
about how bad the movie is while we
watch the movie it's just a big date
with me and my girl
we got food that day it is los angeles
so i partook in some cannabinoids
i would say that was where all of the
money came from entertainment for me was
my lowest and i was so proud of myself
mine was only 63.34
i only had like one big purchase and
that was like taking this girl on a date
and it was like definitely worth it to
me
did she like it she had a really fun
time but also she's afraid of heights so
like i kind of didn't think about that
but it was like a great opportunity for
me to like comfort her
like oh my god no protect you stop it's
fine you loki got game i didn't know
that
yeah i mean it's not a big deal or
anything
so for miscellaneous my girl needed to
pick up her prescription from rite aid
so i got myself
a beard wash i got myself beard oil a
beard balm
i saw this speaker and so i got the
speaker
i did not know that there were that many
products like solely for beards it's
self-care i'm proud of you for that for
my miscellaneous i had
a total of and 88 186.88 but i feel like
it's not fair because i had to buy
textbooks
how are they charging so much for these
books bro like
not even because these are all
electronic rentals
that's the worst part i only have them
for 180 days i'm about to sell this
black market my total spending for the
week
was 1 362
with 18 cents my total with my rent
and fifty was dollars and seventy cents
oh my god
he's so painful to say out loud i was
like dude have i been living like this
i actually decided i was gonna start
budgeting and using this budgeter that i
got
i just don't wanna be stressed when i
open my bank account anymore
it's important to be in charge of your
money yeah wake up call for the both of
us i think
[Music]
you